Çeviri: Aybüke Ekiz
Gözden geçirme: Nihal Aksakal
Bu yolculuğa başladığımda benim bir
hayalim vardı:
Dünyayı değiştirmek.
Çok küçük yaşta ağabeyimin
yönlendirmesiyle bilimle tanıştım.
Her pazar ağabeyim beni sinemaya götürür,
arkasından da bana bir tane bilimsel kitap
alırdı.
Bununla beraber ben bütün
doğum günlerimde ailemden
mikroskop ve teleskop isterdim.
Ailem de bana her doğum günümde
bilimsel deney setleri alırdı.
Haliyle böyle büyüyen bir çocuğun da
bunlarla alakalı bir şeyler yapması
çok normal değildi.
9 yaşında bilgisayarla tanıştım,
kodlamayla tanıştım,
yine ağabeyimin sayesinde.
Bilgisayar, bana farklı bir şey kattı.
Benim, bir insan dışında bir şeye
bir şeyler öğretebileceğim gerçeğini
fark etmemi sağladı aslında.
Oturduğumuz semtte
bir bilim merkezi vardı
ve bir gün anneme dedim ki:
"Anne, ben buraya gitmek istiyorum."
O zamanlar, 4. sınıfa falan gidiyorum,
annem dedi ki:
"Başımıza icat çıkarma oğlum!"
Atalarımız da bunu demişler,
yalnız şöyle bir şey var,
ben dünyayı değiştirmek istiyorken,
icat çıkarmamak
çok doğru olmuyor aslında benim amacımla.
Annemi dinlemedim,
bilim merkezinin sınavına girdim.
Sınavı dereceyle kazandım.
Üç sene boyunca
müfredatta olan bütün konuları
uygulamalı olarak öğrendim.
Bu sırada bu süreç, bana bilimsel
araştırma yapabilme yetkinliği kazandırdı.
İlk projemi
çok heyecanlı bir şekilde bulmuştum.
O günü dün gibi hatırlıyorum.
Danışman hocamın yanına gittim
ve fikrimi anlattım.
O da çok beğendi ve "Hadi yapalım!" dedi.
Başladık, bir sene boyunca uğraştık.
Bir sene sonunda
çalışır bir proje ortaya çıkmıştı.
Daha sonra bununla
bir yarışmaya başvuracaktık.
Yarışmaya başvurduk.
Bir ay her gün mailimi kontrol ettim.
Bir ay sonunda bir mail ulaştı:
"Teşekkür ediyoruz başvurunuz için,
projenizi beğenmedik, kabul etmedik."
Hatta o zamanlara ait çok güzel bir video
var başvuruda kullandığım,
şöyle birazcık izleyelim.
Merhaba, ben Adem Atalay Hüryaşa,
Bayrampaşa Belediyesi bilim merkezi
fen ve teknoloji laboratuvarı
altıncı sınıf öğrencisiyim.
Projemin adı "Her Eve Bir Baraj Projesi."
Şimdi, bir proje yapıyorsunuz,
bir amaç uğruna
ve seçilmemesi demek,
çünkü hani bir yarışmaya katılmak
oradaki asıl amacım,
seçilmemesi benim için çok kötü
bir heves kaybıydı aslında.
Motivasyonum çok düşmüştü,
yalnız dedim ki:
"Ben dünyayı değiştireceğim,
ben yılmayacağım,
bunu başaracağım.
Hemen ikinci bir proje yaptım.
İkinci projede
başvuruyu yaptıktan sonra kabul geldi,
yalnız ikinci aşamada bu da başarısızdı.
Dedim ki "Bu kadar başarısızlık yeter.
Ben dünyayı değiştirmek istiyorken
bu kadar başarısızlıkla
nasıl dünyayı değiştireceğim?"
Proje akademisi diye bir oluşum kurdum.
Bu oluşumun amacı
normalde yarışmalarda var olan
birinci, ikinci, üçüncü gibi
sistemal yapıdan çıkıp
bambaşka bir şey yapmaktı.
Proje yapan bütün öğrencilere
motivasyon sağlaması amacıyla
herkesin ödül alabileceği
bir sistem kurmuştum.
Toplamda iki tane başvuru geldi,
ikisi de benim projelerimdi.
Başarısızlık için yaptığım bir proje de
başarısız olmuştu.
Ne yapacağımı bilmiyordum.
O dönemlerde liseye geçtim, lisede
her akşam etkinliklere gidiyordum.
Annem ve babam, çok sağ olsunlar,
çok destek oldular, engellemediler beni.
İyi ki de engellememişler.
Bir senede
iki yüz elli tane etkinliğe gittim.
Bu etkinliklerin bir tanesinde
etkinlik, planlanan satten
yarım saat erken bitti.
Etkinliği düzenleyen kişi dedi ki,
"Konuşmak isteyen birisi var mı?"
Cahil cesareti, elimi kaldırdım,
kendimi anlatmaya başladım.
O andan sonra hayatım için bir şeylerin
farklı gitmeye başladığını
hissedebiliyordum,
çünkü tekliflerin
ardı arkası kesilmiyordu.
O etkinlikte ben,
Maker Hareketi ile tanıştım.
Maker Hareketi,
açık inovasyonun halka indirilmesi,
üretimin en küçük hanelere,
evlere gelmesi.
Harika bir şeydi.
3D printer'ları görünce büyüleniyordum,
çünkü bir şey üretmek için
fabrikaya gerek yoktu,
ben kendi evimde onu,
kendi üç boyutlu yazıcımla
üretebiliyordum.
Bu, bir devrim olacaktı, belliydi,
ve ben de bu devrimin içindeydim.
Ben de bir Maker'dım,
ve emin olun, siz de Maker'sınız.
İlla elektronikle uğraşmanıza,
yazılımla uğraşmanıza gerek yok.
Yemek yapıyorsanız evet,
siz de üretiyorsunuz.
Daha sonra bir akşam
bir mail geldi.
On dört yaşındayım.
Bana bir toplantı yapmak istediklerini
söylediler.
Şimdi on dört yaşındaki bir çocuk için
bir toplantı, kafamda bir soru işareti.
Haliyle, annemle babamın da kafasında
bir soru işareti oluşturuyor bu durum.
Neyse,
"Gideceğim ben buna." dedim, gittim.
Gittiğim zaman birisi bana
bir teklifte bulundu.
"Böyle bir projem var, yazılım tarafına da
bir ortak arıyorum."
Direkt kabul ettim.
Dedim ki: "Başarısız olursak olalım
ama ben deneyerek
tecrübe kazanmak istiyorum."
Projeye ortak olduk, her şey
iyi gidiyordu.
Birkaç ödül kazandık,
bir sürü kuaförle anlaştık.
Bu arada "Makasla" benim ilk girişimim.
"Makasla", kadınların kuaförlerden
randevu alabileceği bir platform aslında.
Her şey çok iyi gidiyordu.
Beyaz yakalı kadınların gerçekten
böyle bir sisteme ihtiyacı vardı.
Yatırımcılar
bize yatırım yapmak istiyordu.
Bir tane de rakibimiz vardı.
O sıralarda tecrübesizliğimizden kaynaklı
beklentiyi yönetemedik
ve proje, tahmin edeceğiniz üzere,
başarısız oldu.
Daha sonra dedim ki,
"Ben bu kültürü, Maker Hareketini,
girişimciliği,
kendi yaşıtlarıma anlatayım."
Çünkü,
en güzel beni benim yaşıtlarım anlar.
Benim yaşıtlarım da en güzel benden anlar,
çünkü otuz yaşında bir adamın gelip
kendi hayat tecrübelerini anlatması
onlar için çok uzakta kalabiliyordu.
Ama kendi yaşıtlarının, kendi yaşlarında
bunları deneyimlemiş birinin
gelip bunları anlatması harikaydı.
Etkinliklere gittim, konuşmalar yaptım,
eğitimler verdim.
Daha sonra o eğitimlerin birinde
birisiyle tanıştım ve dedik ki:
"Biz Maker Hareketini dahil edebileceğimiz
bir proje yapalım."
Modüler bir Drone geliştirelim,
bu programlanabilsin
ve eğitim teknolojilerinde kullanılsın.
Projeyi yaptık yapmasına,
yalnız bir ay öncesine kadar
ben bu projeden ayrıldım,
çünkü iki ortak olarak
hayallerimiz farklıydı
ve ben dünyayı değiştirmek istiyordum.
Bu proje de aslında
benim için başarısız olmuştu.
Yalnız dedim ki, "Ben dünyayı değiştirmek
istiyorsam,
önce dünyayı dolaşmam gerekiyor,
dünyayı bir görmem gerekiyor.
Yazın İngiltere'ye gittim,
oradaki üniversiteleri, atölyeleri gezdim.
Girişimlerin ofislerini dolaştım.
Oradaki kültürü kokladım.
Aslında hiçbir farkımız yok,
buradaki kültür aynı.
Tek fark isteksizlik.
Gerçekten,
istersek yapamayacağımız hiçbir şey yok.
Eskiden bahane ettiğimiz şeylerin
boş olduğunu fark ettim.
3D printerim yok,
ürünümü geliştiremiyorum.
Hepsi yalan.
Aslında hiçbir şeye ihtiyacımız yok.
Harika bir kaynağımız var
ve eminim ki bunun farkında değiliz.
İnternet, her şeyi bulabileceğimiz
mükemmek bir kaynak.
Bunu en iyi şekilde kullanmamız gerekiyor.
İngiltere yetmedi, dedim ki
"Ben buna devam etmek istiyorum."
Zaten bilimsel bir yönüm var,
İsviçre'ye, Cern'e gittim.
Oradaki kültürü kokladım.
Geldikten sonra yapacağım çalışmalarda
her zaman üç tane ana noktaya değinmek
istiyordum.
Teknoloji zaten vardı.
Teknolojinin yanına bilimi
ve sanatı eklemek istiyordum.
ROST'u kurdum.
ROST, aslında
bizim sadece istediğimiz şeyleri
geliştirdiğimiz bir atölye.
İstanbul'da yer alıyor
ve içeriye sadece hayal gücü derin olan
insanlar girebiliyor, yani herkes.
Aslında hayal gücü bizim içimizde var
ama sadece bizim bu hayal gücünü
kullanmamıza imkan sağlanmıyor.
Biz burada sadece
kendi istediğimiz şeyleri geliştiriyoruz.
Yapay zekalar, robotlar...
Tabii, sürekli
başarısızlıkları anlatıyorum
ama bunların arasında
çeşitli başarılar da var.
Dünya devi Google'ın düzenlediği
yarışmadan aldığım bir ödül.
Yine bu projeler de aslında o motivasyonun
kırıldığı halde,
o kopma noktasından kurtaran şeyler
ama emin olun siz bir şeyler
yaptıktan sonra,
o kopma noktalarını kurtaran
B planları her zaman hazır oluyor.
Dünyayı değiştirmek diyordum,
bir anda başarı, başarısızlık,
bir şeyler anlatıyorum.
Aslında dünyayı değiştirmek
bana göre insanı değiştirmek.
Ben bunu çok yeni anladım.
PIRA'yla ayrıldığımız gün bana bir mesaj
geldi Facebook üzerinden.
İngiltere'de tanıştığım
ve bana programlamaya başlamak istediğini
söyleyen bir genç bana mesaj atmıştı.
Benim sayemde hayatının
işleyişini değiştirdiğini söylüyordu bana.
Bu harika bir şeydi.
Gerçekten bir insanın hayatına dokunduğumu
o an fark ettim,
çünkü o kişi bundan sonraki süreçte
benden aldığı etkiyle
hayatına devam etmek
istediğini söylüyordu.
Dünyayı değiştirmek dediğimiz zincirde
ağabeyimin benim hayatımı değiştirmesi,
benim de Flippo'nun hayatını değiştirmem,
ve Flippo'nun da değiştireceği diğer kişi,
aslında burada bir
domino etkisi oluşturacak
ve dünya bu şekilde değişecek.
Aynı zamanda burada, şu an TEDx Ankara'da
konuşmamızın asıl nedeni de
bu üç bin kişi arasından
bir kişinin hayatını değiştirebilirsek
o domino etkisini devam ettirebilmek,
sürdürebilmek.
Dünya çok hızlı gelişiyor.
Yapay zeka.
Artık insanların haklarından ziyade
yapay zekaların hakları tartışılıyor.
O yüzden durmamamız gerekiyor.
Tükettiğimizden fazla üretmemiz gerekiyor.
Zaman çok hızlı, değişim çok hızlı.
Yetişmemiz gerekiyor.
Üretmek bir insanın
ulaşabileceği en üst nokta
ve bunu gerçekten yakalayabiliriz,
bu içimizde var.
O yüzden, fazla beklemeyin.
Harekete geçin,
gelin dünyayı beraber değiştirelim.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)